well all right continuing coverage of
the closure of desert inn road on the
east side of town you know we've had
live reports from where they are
methodically demolishing and rebuilding
that short little bridge on the 95
between boulder highway and flamingo
well that short bridge just happens to
cross over di
between sandhill
and just before the curve where it turns
into lamb endos adrian packer says that
tiny part of the freeway over desert inn
road is old the d.i bridge i think was
finished in 1987 so it's it's reached
its age limit good news for freeway
drivers no closures during the
demolition just shifting lanes during
what adrienne says is a precision
operation this
demolition is kind of like a surgical
procedure
they have to like keep the abutments
intact and and not do any damage to it
also the businesses on d.i just east of
sandhill want you to know they're still
open because local traffic is allowed
however drivers who think they can sneak
through
you'll find another set of barriers just
before the actual construction so this
closure scheduled to wrap up this
weekend round two that'll be in october
then they'll complete it after another
closure either late this year or in
early 2022. a whole bunch of potential
detours we've got them in the online
version of this story we also have a
link to the ndot website
i515project.com along with all of our
driving you crazy stories at
8newsnow.com click traffic then driving
you crazy buckle up drive carefully
please put down that taco if there's
something driving you crazy email me
traffic 8 8newsnow.com